in the pursuit of greatness we are asked
to give our lives away to relinquish our
time our energy and our bodies all to
reach the top of our chosen field to
become the greatest to have ever lived
to become a champion now waited for
[ __ ] New Year so to say in dota 2
that pinnacle is the International the
biggest eSports tournament on the planet
it all comes down to this
like what up
you're canceled three my angel
eleven
this is the story of teams risking it
all for greatness the story of people
laying everything on the line for the
privilege of hoisting the ever-elusive
aegis of Champions in front of thousands
of fans this is the story of the
International the International maybe
the biggest tournament in eSports today
but its beginnings were humble in August
of 2011 valve hosted the first-ever Ti
at Gamescom in Cologne as a coming-out
party for dota 2 the sequel to popular
Warcraft 3 mod Defense of the Ancients
but the game which was still in beta at
the time did not make a great first
impression with the diehards and at
first players were reluctant to move to
an updated version of a game that they'd
poured their hearts and souls into maybe
one guy like this I thought it was
pretty cool too but everybody wasn't
like what the [ __ ] is this the initial
reaction not just for myself was just
like this this isn't dota on top of
grappling with an unfinished buggy game
the players didn't receive beta keys
until a couple weeks out from the event
an event that boasts the largest cash
prize eSports had ever seen despite the
bugs how alien the game felt for
everyone involved and many players
showing up with a relaxed attitude one
team not as Vince air showed up to win
your assault confidence I remember we
were so confident that we going to win
because I joined the game and I feel so
free Dendi was the face of na'vi and the
ukrainian middle ater more or less wrote
the book on proactive mid-play seizing
any opportunity to change a game and it
was that aggressive approach that helped
Navi breathe through the events
eventually Navi would face Chinese
powerhouse Evo in the grand finals and
although the Chinese team would to hit
game off the Ukrainians a feat no other
team managed throughout the tournament
Navi would prevail they are running
forward to 1 million dollars
the jab for the for the change
but this clash between Europe and China
would not be an isolated one in fact it
would set the tone for dota 2 in the
International for years to come
by the time TI 2 rolled around dota 2
had a full year of play under its belt
and the game had taken off in a big way
resulting in the international being
moved to the Benaroya Hall in Seattle
Washington but the storyline of TI 2
centered around na'vi and whether china
the dominant region in the competitive
circuit had truly closed the gap enough
to de throne the defending European
champions and during the group stage
that appeared to be the case as Navi
dropped more games in LGD gaming and
victus gaming and team DK combined but
in the second round of the upper bracket
na'vi ran into group b winners Invictus
gaming despite having the odds stacked
against them na'vi reminded everyone why
they had been TI champions by producing
one of the greatest plays in dota 2
history simply known as the play they
swarm up the river patience from so
waiting in the wave now he is about to
be caught oh there's been sleep but sir
he catches everyone oh this could be a
total disaster
that twine trying to survive trots gonna
go down
puppy talked about the Nagas canner and
try the Bevin would this BKB they turned
it around
standing ovation from the crowd after
sending Invictus gaming down to the
lower bracket na'vi then managed to
upset an undefeated LGD gaming in the
upper bracket finals punching their
ticket to yet another international
grand final but Navi for the third time
in a row take down one of these top
Chinese teams after losing Game one they
are proving to be the champions they
were last year there they would rematch
Invictus gaming who had valiantly clawed
their way out of a stacked lower bracket
with 1 million dollars and a regional
pride on the line Europe and China
clashed again but this time Navi was in
over their head
where's that silent oppose splits with
the images but too much damn it it's too
much damn it pose take the bull a medium
limit but it might be too late it looks
like puppy going to go down flitter
connects again the support three big
works
diving diving Ferrari he's overextended
slowed down Phobos
silence signs again queen of pain top
spot fires out Dendi dropping low fave
dropping low hobo's balls to death let's
see a buyback Blanco a puppy they catch
him there won't be no steal the genies
come out and I do take it tried a big
celebration breath he jumps out of the
seat again he's trying to fight
everybody I hope volts by clicking away
but you can't take everybody
slow but knobby players are dying threes
that teaches called GG is called IG
issue champion for international to
China had exacted revenge for its
previous TI defeat and now the rest of
the world would have to wait another
year
to knock them off their perch
with the tremendous success of TI to the
states where the international three had
to be raised and valves introduction of
the compendium in 2013 did just that now
a TI staple the compendium allows dota 2
players to help support the
International as an incentive to buy it
valve implemented a tiered reward system
that gave players in-game cosmetics each
time a crowdfunding goal blew up and
pledged to donate 25% of the money they
received from compendium purchases
toward TI's prize pool and looking back
it's release might be one of the most
significant moments in not just the
history of dota but all of esports from
the get-go the compendium was a hint
boosting ti3 is price fooled by more
than 1.2 million dollars for a grand
total of two point eight seven million
with the largest cash prize in eSports
history on the line it was up to the
team to deliver the entertainment and
data they ever wore staff tries to get
into safety does not have carapace
shackleshot almost-perfect was perfect
but the impale caught everyone as well
Kuro now with the café's counter
initiation Dell goes the wall that's
just the most chocolate win on banana
dough
gets the kill now he's going to be able
to work on qingcheng here comes Dendi
vacuum into the wall once again he's
dismembering move going to tell enema
ghost makes it a gentle kill now they're
going to get another one
no be charging back on it KJ make it a
five man right go be careful bleak BKB
black holes back up again very badly
crew priorities and jumping up be
skillfully feet can be wearing a double
kill for a higher sample of garganta
triple Cal for a liar and kukuku is on
the rubber Butchie says nor double kill
we have our B in 20 seconds it will
there be 21 seconds I'm not sure Tyler
good good for DC they don't get these
people come to us dead not yet
and father is on his feet
a year after the Chinese dota scene flex
their strength the region dominated TI
threes bracket stage and while not us
Vincere were in the running to make
their third consecutive TI grand final
there was another european team making
waves on DotA's biggest stage alliance
triple kill tripoli absolutely crushing
performance and DK will tap out and the
alliance are guaranteed a top three
finish at the international three you
can take a game of them but good luck
taking a series will we Swedish roster
the featured the likes of alota
s4 and admiralbulldog alliance were one
of the hottest teams coming into TI
three and were in the midst of one of
the most impressive seasons in dota 2
history having gone undefeated in the
group stage aligns faced off against
Navi in the upper bracket and swept them
down to the lower bracket once their
Navi would face orange esports who had
just upset both DK & tongfu in
back-to-back series during Game three
orange was on the brink of upsetting
Navi as well until KY XY committed one
of the costliest mistakes and dota 2
history the denied need to follow up and
then just deal with this agus when it
comes out should be on the hand too
pushy and micro hands of Windrunner yeah
then I want to deny that they failed all
oh we see a lot of rares ping in and
outs for witnessing Lyle Venegas that's
not really what you want to do KY XY in
a now infamous momentum shifting miss
play that remains hard to watch the
Malaysian carry denied his team both the
aegis of the immortal and ultimately a
grand finals of birth
butchy did now Denny with a sob story
with his dungeons back back in again fat
papa
the national grand final
oranges disastrous exit paved the way
for TI's first-ever all european grand
final and a rematch between na'vi and
alliance in what is widely considered to
be the most memorable grand final series
TI has ever seen creating another face
of a tank that will call out to fly they
bland so bold oh he's still alive though
he's not even dying three dead no track
hills for Navi and they're not gonna get
any make it for now the down to 211 and
then get a GG oh my G 60 minute GG and
they're gonna get that final last kill
Alliance just dominating they want
Bulldog Bulldog chasing it yeah they
just can't stand against this level
damage Papi's still hunting start out
okay they don't even need the black hole
it's a rout
it's a retreat to the ballad they'll
find a sport and sports dead in a matter
of seconds Florida fall their farming
Alliance in their own base this is the
most one-sided game that the Alliance
has lost in this entire tournament in
comes s4 he's found
and kind of up as well this arm against
the fairies not you anything
funding survived initiation I want to be
here longer agent thank you very much
but the fine rapier is now on funnik and
nathi are going to cut alliances head
off down the middle lane
now those backstab on Bulldog he's going
to drop on the footage
lastly an uploader but loda is still
alive he's still gonna satanic of those
days hands and above will fall to
Lourdes toga BKB Bulldog will fall
though I think by back in the death
again and her that's for he's gonna
chase the other dead
Elias the Swedish mundane force again
after trading games back and forth with
unique drafts were all swapping and
heart-wrenching plays the international
had its first ever five-game Grand
Finals it all comes down to this one
more game two million dollars on the
table winner first place at the
international the agent and the prestige
of being the best dota 2 team in the
world and in the end the thrilling final
game was all but decided by s4 and a
pair of legendary dream coil internet
sport he just bought back if he dies
that could be game Blake's away they
take the round all TP TP quick right now
as force gonna try to cancel us and many
as possible you'll cancel three my god
but Nick's gonna try to keep people's
gonna defend against everybody me what
load up and working on the mainly rocks
on the body Briana riffle photic you're
getting spot for he's gonna get back out
for the racks in huge trouble
they won't defend along
he's out he canceled the beat compete
Bobby's not gonna be back in the face
he's got be kidding me
but no boots of travel on its paws now
make over the phone it could be game
footage down Alliance I'm doing it they
need a little far to fall Japanese
legends live it's good being their last
stand
then these back he's gonna try to focus
everybody but there's so much stuff the
place there's no more clubs available
death of a half HP a quarantine Alliance
surrounding from Alsace KB they want it
around they're gonna do it
see
four million dollars
your international strand Chavez the
million-dollar dream coils each test
scores named into dota 2's Pantheon
cemented alliance as the undisputed best
team in the world and provided an
incredible conclusion to what remains
the most exhilarating Grand Finals the
international has ever seen
prior to the beginning of the
International 4-valve and dota fans
started to get a taste of what the
compendium was capable of by the time
the tournament was about to again the
community had raised over nine million
dollars to contribute to the prize pool
making ti4 is ten point nine two million
the largest prize pool in eSports
history the format for the event had
also changed with the top two teams
being awarded byes ahead of the semi
finals in an attempt to make the group
stage feel more significant with that
said the International four wasn't
exactly the most memorable TI and one of
the reasons for that was the death ball
meta which strongly rewarded teams that
executed aggressive early game tactics
before the death ball strategy is
discovering the group stage should have
been pretty exciting as team tried to
navigate their way for the new game
build but once vici gaming and Evil
Geniuses uncovered it all other battle
plans were rendered obsolete game during
the elimination phase of the event were
very one-sided
and it often felt like whichever team
was able to secure the lead early on
would snowball and win with little
potential for comebacks and it was in a
large part thanks to the death ball meta
that North America would get to see its
first deep run at an international title
with Evil Geniuses looking like the best
non Chinese team in the world it's
trapped outside m-my he tried to go in
universe but he defense obliterated
three heroes down the top Rank's will go
as well and that GJ aja through the wind
final but the north-american TI dream
would be short-lived as easy stumbled
over newbie in the upper bracket and
then vici gaming in the lower bracket
finals resulting in TI's first ever all
Chinese Grand Final and it went down is
one of the most anti climactic Grand
Finals of all time
with new be perfectly implementing the
death ball strategy to easily dispatch
their compatriots and shall always be
still not dead the last second the
Empress will get the kill but he'll be
staring down the barrel of another
killer face double kill the hell
newbie are off to a fantastic start here
and game them before the plate will be
prepped up super he tries he humpin on
being picked up and throw it down
he could have time left side he gets it
off she kuchi out for the century boys
till then they can seem the attributed
one Chivers he solo and live no chikara
he goes down as well the two played GG
50
it's our the newbie convincingly moon
wait through the woods
the victory against BG can be here at
ti4 pehle jayegi
game
the International ti4 may have been
tainted by its uninspired meta and a
lackluster finale its record-breaking
prize pool raised mainstream awareness
of the event and the level of prestige
associated with it
after the mixed reaction at ti4 valve
decided to return to the conventional
group and bracket stage formats of
previous tea eyes and that decision
combined with a less restrictive meta
would lead ti5 to being considered one
of the most competitive in the
tournament's history heading into the
event evil geniuses were riding high
after their deep run the previous year
and since adding a 15 year old pub star
named sue mail in January the team had
emerged as one of the non-chinese
favourites to win the event well the
group stage was strongly contested the
bracket phase was still largely
dominated by the Chinese teams and even
eg would find themselves falling down to
the lower bracket
at the hands of seedy crazy dropping low
will get the Mac up the walls mean job
but it doesn't matter who's gonna go
down University's gonna have to surge
himself away but aggressive and cuter
universe to fall leave me G just
happened to get himself out of there
with some mail the track on Samantha
gonna continue to chase this down then
feel the vision on the BB D mail the
only last man standing after their loss
to see Dec DG was staring down
elimination and their last chance in
making grand finals relied on overcoming
another giant of Chinese dota in LGD
gaming and they did
sumail gets the kill and now he looks
together
pika miette 4z
Gidi
so time to think about it in the more
getting new to smithereens
Universal mostly Navarre he threatened
tickly retreats he will survive for now
University of fishing for a buck but he
doesn't need to kill
for the second time in the
internationals history a grand final
would be decided in an upper bracket
final rematch all that stood between eg
and n A's first TI championship was the
imperious CDs after taking two of the
first three games
eg looked to carry their momentum into
the fourth and nearly 30 minutes into
that game Evil Geniuses emphatically
slammed the door shut on CD EC and China
hopes of claiming another TI title I
don't think either interested in
contesting the spark fire but maybe they
can lay it long enough for it to be a
five-on-five if they ice blast and
Fisher properly there is no hook shot
there altogether PPT here comes the ice
floss or any
off the back of the six million dollar
echo slam perhaps the most iconic dota 2
play in a recent memory
evil geniuses close out the match
universe alley 2000 fear PPD and sumail
had done it they had finally given na
its first ever th championship and they
did so in the most spectacular fashion
by now you may have noticed a trend
within the International every other
year China brings home the title that
meant that when it was time for the
International in 2016 and it's more than
twenty million dollar prize pool all
eyes were on DotA's most decorated
region but standing in China's way or
defending champs evil geniuses who
looked primed to make another run at the
aegis after the dust settled and the
brackets were set things look just about
how you'd expect including eg and in
their second round upper bracket clash
against eHome evil geniuses treated dota
2 fans to one of the greatest comebacks
of all time finding themselves twenty
thousand gold down after the 40-minute
mark and with a home securing mega
creeps 30 minutes later evil geniuses
dug in and fought desperately for their
tournament lives still five up but here
comes Ted on these flash bouncing around
a shattered even hoping to be able to go
inside but it
the mail just filled up but he still
managed to get himself away in the back
light the spaceless
and now it's gonna run in some place
universe set these fabulous
for the whole planet
he's back besides Iranian space he's
already taken down one of the tier fours
and he's trying to get PPD but evil
geniuses pull top elected they're
holding us events here
no this is the in-game scenario 60
seconds without this jug a home can they
hold Ichi confident they can't
here's coming up as well the tier 4
eg did what nobody had ever done before
at a TI coming back from mega creeps to
keep their hopes of back-to-back titles
alive but despite their tremendous
performance na is defending champions
bowed out of ti6
at the hands of China's Wings gaming and
another and a team in the lower bracket
digital ki once more they're building an
army Mon
these illusions turned against DG let's
leave
they can't clear the set on faith they
do up rabbit soon 15 seconds but so many
ways to deal with the two hours they're
falling we hace get around ten boys
pulling it out candg answers it's all on
uni now the clip is down universe rabbit
P can be
we straight for the jugular under the
Bonavista reso
they hold for now here's coming up with
a vengeance
they have come
a team
captain lieutenant
after losing two wings earlier in the
upper bracket DC read a gauntlet of
tough opposition to earn their shot at
redemption in the grand finals this is
the only team who could handle the lower
bracket and I don't know how they did it
and they deserve so much credit and I
think they've just got to do it now you
can't have this journey and not win once
again the largest prize pool in eSports
history will be decided between North
America and China and while digital
chaos fought courageously wings would
not be denied
once again China raised the aegis of
champions at the expense of na and the
rest of the world shattered TI dreams
the International is a tournament that
is defined just as much by heartbreak as
it is by historic victories and crazy
plays and no one embodied that
heartbreak heading into TI seven more
than kuroky he was always a celebrated
name but one haunted by a series of
crushing disappointments that trend of
falling short looked to continue in 2017
when a liquid world emanated from the
upper bracket in the first round liquid
are down there now a corpse that's being
punched kicked and about to be put Six
Feet Under
IG have the buybacks that they need them
they've got the damage they've got the
control the position is theirs
the game is theirs the series is theirs
and top six is
Wow all eyes want a liquid were once
favored to win the tournament but now
had one of the longest roads to make it
to the grand finals and under kuroky
leadership they rallied the drop still
they fight on for v5 last press for
secret as they charged it they want that
trough they passion back control of all
they can already another duel one bid
once down it's all over her secret
jaga's jump float from miracle looking
from the post crew gets the glutes back
but he's already gone before shut down
for 40 Roger corrosive hazed up as well
maja aces in resolution moving in but
Gigi good luck next is caught by Empire
ISM but a totally getting last a little
bit longer they have to damage output
they move forward
winter stunt words the control blanket
now I'm very change it runs forever risk
of the chief the bt's they're coming in
ancient sea doing the work the team
Deborah Tolman look you're gonna kill
under no one that's the one they have
forget the fortress until fortified no
one will fall down my back have to be
committed
you've still another three came life on
that agent have miracle their holdings
their holdings they're doing
teamliquid from all sides be standing up
on burgers Pro the t3 tower in the mid
will now fall where is the defense you
don't have colonel I'll be sonic wave
after getting the best virtus Pro in an
insane series liquid completed their
unbelievable run back to Grand Finals by
toppling LGD gaming and then LGD for
every young in the lower bracket - he
marches in one foot in front of the
other but now he does get last so
tieless up as well he's got aegis
he's got the BKB thunder being countered
out here it looks like at least for now
miracle though get all JC boom cat died
here commitment he's so deep it's so
damn did it
muttering fights back they folks out the
buy back when it comes in
Superman ma can he hold the bandsaw
barrels in on his own he needs a little
help he's gonna need it soon eh coming
from behind they lock them down can they
kill him once the base is crumbling top
it death by a thousand cuts on a chair
for mind control [ __ ] that me gave me
he's down the half can they actually
and in Grand Finals liquid had just one
dangerous obstacle between their captain
and his dream newbie but the upper
bracket winners were simply no match and
not committing too heavily and with the
been immense memory as that BKB to
reaction types was all about miracle the
virus our kataka he'll connect all up
fish mcafee he'll get the son of the
middle so close the middle to build us a
new car tada
take a breath they prefer me out they
come once more
after years of dedication years of
painful disappointment
kuroky sacrifice was finally rewarded
the biggest stage the most money and
fans from all over the world screaming
as you compete for the aegis of
Champions the International is the
shining star a top esports Ti is it it's
do or die make or break when you retire
from the game your whole career will be
defined by how you perform at this event
that takes place only once a year as
other eSports have grown and spread
their roots into corporate sponsorships
and gain big investments through
franchise systems dota has stood still
it is the last remaining relic of the
grind relinquishing your life to a game
to realize its greatest reward or to
come up short TI is so enthralling but
it defines an entire game it breaks
records and it breaks hearts there's no
doubt that this pinnacle of gaming
immortality offers a precarious means to
defining your career by but every year
they come and every year dozens the
stories are written into this events
illustrious history because some things
are worth giving it your all for thanks
for watching if you want more great
content just like this be sure to hit
the subscribe button